[Music]
these elections are getting longer and
longer and longer and longer and i
really believe that this election cycle
began
about 66 months ago and uh i think it
actually began when i was about 14 years
old
and now here we are we're coming up to
the to the final weeks
people have tons of information
and there's still these undecided voters
which can sometimes sometimes i wonder
are they doing it to just get attention
like still not sure
to be an undecided voter in this
election i think you know if you're
undecided at this point you're either an
astronaut and you've been at the space
station for the last couple months or
you've been in a coma i don't know how
you can be agnostic given the the sort
of very very different path
each party wants to put the country on
um but apparently there are people that
you know either haven't been paying
attention or just really don't know how
they feel about you know the vision
offered by the republicans that offered
by the democrats
uh you know i have
other people have had the same
observation and but i've i've sort of
shared this feeling a little bit which
is that i watch
you know
there are times when we're all aware
that there's a politician say a bill
clinton who clearly just loves politics
loves the game
even if they
people tell them okay you can check out
now and go have a doughnut they want to
stay
work the crowd talk to people it's their
lifeblood i almost get the feeling with
both of these kansas both the president
and mitt romney that it's maybe not
their first choice a love of being a
politician is that possible i think that
that's a fairly astute observation conan
um
the thing when you talk about clinton
it's amazing that he's on the campaign
trail because he is such an animal about
this stuff and at the dnc at the
convention there was this incredible
moment where clinton was done speaking
you know obama came out there and they
gave each other daps or whatever and and
obama's like all right i'm ready to go
off the stage and clinton just stayed
there and kind of waited because he
wasn't done because he loves the game to
your point about romney and obama um i
think obama is in it because he feels a
higher calling not that he likes doing
it but he really feels like he can do
something better for the country to some
degree i think mitt romney is the same
way but they are both kind of boss
they're like bosses
obama's the guy that you want to the
boss that you'd have a drink at the
water cooler with romney's the guy that
would come to the water cooler and say
shouldn't you be at your desk right um
uh
you know i don't think he has a love of
the game uh in the same way that you
know bill clinton did and i'm not quite
sure why he wants to be president other
than the fact that it seems like the
next thing he should be doing with his
life and of course his father's failed
bid at the presidency i think is an
animating factor okay let me ask you
quickly you've had uh
someone asked you recently what your
dream guest would be
and uh
you said i i saw you give this answer
that it would be uh the the speaker of
the house john boehner and i was
thinking that's your dream guest
why why is your dream guess i'm always
thinking of like reunite aerosmith
she loves tan man yeah i was going to
say john boehner like would be better
who is more i mean first of all has the
worst job in american politics has to
deal with the the herd of cats that is
the house republican caucus he cries at
everything that's fun and loves red wine
and smoking this man is a politician
like no other i will also say conan in a
bit a transparency a very shallow one i
cry whenever boehner cries when he cries
something about his face crumpling in
that sort of
horribly contorted way it's not just
because he looks bad when he cries it's
something about the human condition and
so i just want him on to have some
merlot and cry
you know what's funny the thought of you
crying makes me cry
i'm crying the three of us should get
together
and just drink a lot of merlot and just
cry that is ratings goals
you and i can lose boehner
take a little walk
[Applause]